do you think that Trump represents  anything legitimate in the Republican  Party or among the American politics  well he is like number two he is he is  appealing to a segment that I'll just  label racist and and it exists and it's  out there and you know what I don't want  to have anything to do with it I don't  want to have anything to do with it  embarrasses it embarrasses me and like I  say I think that the electorate will  paint the entire Republican Party with  with a broad brush as a result of Trump  and it won't be a positive and because  he's deported to Mexicans they'll have  to paint the round three and he employs  tens of thousands of people and he's in  the service industry how many of those  are immigrants I mean IIIi don't I don't  get why any of them remain around